is this the end Mr Johnson
once a prime minister now out of office
out of Parliament and for now out of
political Road
after a 14-month investigation finally
time for the verdict did Boris Johnson
mislead Parliament over partygate a
unanimous yes from the Privileges
committee its report damning of Boris
Johnson's conduct and character accusing
him of having deliberately misled the
House of Commons and the committee
investigating him
impugning their work undermining the
Democratic process while being complicit
in the campaign of abuse and attempted
intimidation of the committee
enough to recommend a suspension of 90
days if he was still an MP far exceeding
the period needed to trigger a
by-election and a recommendation that
his parliamentary member's pass be
withdrawn
Boris Johnson he's not only a law
breaker but a layer he's not fit for
public office and he's disgraced himself
and continues to act like a you know
pound shot Trump in the way in which he
tries to discredit anybody who
criticizes his actions when actually a
decent public servant would have done
the honorable thing would have had a
little bit of humility and would have
apologized an apology the last thing on
Mr Johnson's mind instead pure anger the
committee now says that I deliberately
misled the house and at the moment I
spoke I was consciously concealing from
the house my knowledge of illicit events
this is rubbish it is a lie he went on
to say this report is a charade I was
wrong to believe in the committee or its
good faith the terrible truth is that it
is not I who has trusted the truth to
suit my purposes it is Harriet Harman
and her committee this is a dreadful day
for MP fees and for democracy MPS in
here agreeing with him but for very
different reasons Boris Johnson lied
he lied to MPS he lied to the people of
this country he lied to nurses doctors
care workers bus drivers everyone as I
read this report this morning I thought
of all those people including
constituents of mine who couldn't say
goodbye as loved ones Lay Dying when
they hear these headlines they will be
forced to relive their own hurt and
anger
MPS will vote on Monday to pass their
judgment the leader of the House clear
members will decide free from party
pressure it will be a painful process
and a sad process for all of us the task
that we uh we face on Monday but all of
us must do what we think is right and
others must leave us alone to do so you
have the whole of the opposition against
him but you also have the Boris haters
and the conservative party so this one
of Boris Johnson's biggest allies
confident he'll lose the vote but also
sure this is not the end is he too
damaged from this can he combat really
combat it depends on the Judgment people
come to I think many people will look at
90 days and will think that that is
simply too harsh too aggressive and
shows what the committee was really
trying to do I think this will generate
sympathy for him but he is still a
popular National figure he still has a
connection with voters that most
politicians would give their eye teeth
full this vdm struggling in the polls
and struggling with his former boss on
an immigration visit this morning far
away from Westminster but not the drama
engulfing his party and what a drama
it's been three separate party gate
investigations that resulted in police
fines the resignation of Boris Johnson
as pm and now his departure as an MP it
has been a psychodrama that has
distracted and disrupted the
conservative party and the government
and while the report is now concluded
the investigations Are Over The Fallout
continues with a party now divided by
elections on the way and a frenzy around
what Boris Johnson might do next
Boris Johnson dominated here after his
2019 Triumph now ejected from Parliament
disgraced he nevertheless looms large
keeping his options open and casting a
shadow over his successors still Beth
Rigby Sky News in Westminster